W YORKMOE
CONFIDENCE OF RELF
FOO SEXU HARASSED AT
LEAST ND A WORN.R TOUCHING
IHT I COU HERN AALGOERNSHER SES
TK I DON' INOTHDE SORRY.I BREE
A
DIDN'T TAK
HET  AINWRONG.OLOGIZE AND
HAD , BUT HIS LIF
ONT  COMIN  THARVIVOROF
TRAUMA SL N'
FERENCE BETWEEN
NT
ONETS CALLING
NO RESIG A  OASSEMBLY.
THK TH
US.
CALLING FOGOVERNOR'S
RESIN FO
CO
T DO YOUIE
GOVERNOR HAS AINALLY SEGISLATURE
THROUGK D
THE UNITED STATES THAT GNO RESI
IMHM
PRHEF TH
THE PARTS A AITSN LIGROSS MISCO
LIL BI A THID DE
PRESIDBID SAID
CALLING ALL
LAS ALR S
IMPEHEATHEQUESTI DIN
I WOULD SA 168SEENTATION
AS WELL AS 179 PEOPLE  IED ON T
HARASSMENT, ONHE 11 BRAVE
CONDUCTEIN THE
LETICIA JAS.
YN TWITTER THATDO PREE
IEHIARWH YOUR WAS WHEN THEOVPL
>> I DH K
AND WHOUNGND, POWERFUL I MINK A
UR SEXUAABUSE,  TT O AN  ABOUTS
E MINDOF
VICTIMD AN
DIR  PAITOE S RUP TONOPET THESEM
NOT FEELOL HE WAOGETIC TOTHESE .
ALVALIDISRUPT THLE'SELLIOT SPITD
BASED ON WHAT YOU KNOW OF
VE CUOMO, WHY  THINK
HE RESIGNEES IT'FUOU
SEFA
WENOW WHY IT'S VERY
IC COMATS TIME FORHIM TOWNO WE
OF NTO
THE TMSFATHER
WANTED TO E
.DOWITH WHO H SAWIOT R
DECI T LESS
THE SE TO
CESTIGATION
GA DOCUMENTATION AAGE TOGETHERTS
SUFFICIENT ANDSTANTIVEENOU THEE
E ASSEMBLYY TEXOME
OUG?E'RE DTHOUSANDS OFE DETERMIN
WILBE OENT COORR T ARAL
VE T NURSING
M BRIDGE,
ING OUAT
PRTEHAUP
E DOCUMENTS AND  STRONAG EVIDEN
THPRESENT TO THE SENATCOURT